hey guys Pete peppers here and I was
gonna do a little gameplay preview of a
new game from King that is called senior
Waleed's
rescue clicker and it is I don't know
who Senor Walid is um guess it's one of
these guys down here but this is a
continuation of the Pet Rescue saga
series so I think people will be really
excited about it this is our map here
you can see that there's some normal map
but then we also have some cool stuff on
the side so I'll show you just real
quick the basic look it takes right and
you can see we have some other stuff
like some help available and things but
looks just like an updated version of
the original game which is cool we have
this maybe Senor Walid who knows but we
have the turtle he tells us that if we
click on the bomb then that will explode
the blocks and we have to collect three
dogs here so we go ahead and blow the
bomb up and just work my way to the
bottom we also have this guy he could be
Senor Walid maybe he when his meter
fills up then we can actually drop an
anchor down to take out one of these
rows go ahead and use the bomb for those
two and the bomb for that one too all
right so we collected our three pets
pretty cool animation there with the
lifesaver coming in air rescuing them
out and you could see that you know it
it's it's definitely you know like in
the vein of candy crush soda or jelly
you know definitely from the franchise
game Pet Rescue saga so you can see that
once we complete the levels there's a
tally down here to add to the stars
and then there's also ones where our
friends need help and you can see those
on the side too so like on this one it's
rainy on there we click on it and it
says that these two friends one friend
needs help one is offering help so go
ahead and play and this is a whole
different version of the level now here
we have the pet submerged in water and
the turtle will tell us that we have to
bring them up so this is pretty cool
it's also kind of candy crush soda style
but they're inside their little bubbles
there we click on pieces above and they
float to the top so I like I like I
always like new stuff and this is um
there's something that jumped out to me
right away we'll go ahead and rescue
these guys and I'll show you a couple
other things that I've picked up just by
I just I just got ahold of this
yesterday it's it's important to keep in
mind this is a really early version
though probably a lot of changes this is
you know basically a we can send our
friend some help now that we have it
there seems to be a trend where they're
putting the games out in soft-launched
right away or really early in the
development process so they can work out
the bugs with a with a real playing
audience so you know there you'll see a
lot of changes in the way it looks and
the you know the different different
things now here I was looking at this
yesterday it says group rescued you
rescued so on the lightning rescue party
it seems like we work together and we
can we can actually win gold bars on
those that was the prize at this point I
can't actually hook up to Facebook I
can't connect yet so no chance I'm
winning those prizes but that would be
something that I'm making a cool feature
later on in the game
see they're broken the maps broken up in
the cities so we have different
different styles for each one different
different rescue journeys they're called
here's some other you know features we
got the blocks here so we have to use
these boxes to bring them down figure
out which way the dog goes he's not
going that way I guess so we'll go this
way and then we'll need to break out
these blocks with the thing and don't
worry you won't kill your dog so now
they're coming this way
or he is anyways I've played I played
the original Pet Rescue saga quite a bit
I'm definitely not an expert at this
though so it's been a lot of fun to
learn the features and see what it's
basically just a brand new game for me
so that's pretty cool I think it'll be
really popular because the other one is
really popular and you can see here
these are where our friends are asking
for help and they'll take us right to it
he needs our help
so this is another submerged version so
the dogs look pretty cool trapped in
their little bubbles everything it's
like we have to work to the outside oh
here's another little thing that the box
of box of rockets those take out the
whatever color they are so you can see
that's smashing up a lot of a lot of
space for me well yeah it seems like it
seems like it's it it's it's got a lot
of even in the early version here it's
got a lot of cool new stuff added to it
sure this will make people who love the
original happy and I think it'll be a
little bit I think it would be
interesting to those of us who kind of
stopped playing the other one so you
know because newer games came out and
whatnot and we'll have a chance to you
know get into it when it's it seems like
what these sister titles they really
they really take a you know they take
from everything that's good about the
original game and then add stuff that
they realized later that could make it
better so it's it's you know like with
soda I think soda is just way cooler at
least like technically than the original
candy crush's so I think this is a
probably in the same ballpark but leave
some comments if you have questions
about it you know well I'll be playing
this one for a while I think if the I
think once it comes out I'll probably I
have a friend who does at rescue so I'll
probably not actually pursue the game
but I wanted to give you guys a tall
look of it if you got any questions let
me know
if you would like to see more videos
like this then definitely subscribe to
my channel because I try to put out
everything new when it comes out so that
you can get an idea of what to expect in
the near future I'm gonna see if I can
yeah here we go this is the anchor I was
talking about so the anchor you should
charge up the charge up his meter there
move it to whichever rail you want and
then you can drop it and it takes out an
entire row and in this case you could
see we would have needed it to pick up
that one so that's the end of the video
I hope you enjoyed it I hope you'll
subscribe like the video and leave
comments if you have any questions
Thanks